françois davy et qui est maire de balme
de sillingy est avec nous bonjour
monsieur oui bonjour bon ben c'est
comment tu avais vous puisque vous avez
été vous avez été
vous avez été frappés par le virus une
bonne grippe on peut dire comment vous
vous en êtes arrivé à la l'idée ou à la
conclusion que vous pouviez être atteint
par le corona virus tout simplement
parce que dans les six premiers qui sont
déclarés en haute savoie il y avait mon
frère et des amis avec qui on avait fait
une soirée vous quels ont été les
premiers symptômes principalement des
frissons mal à la tête et de la toux et
on a continué un petit peu nos activités
principalement à la mairie en fermant
les écoles et les crèches le premier
jour puis les associations les bâtiments
publics
le deuxième parce que on est rapidement
monté avec des cas nouveau donc
moi j'ai plutôt appliquer le principe de
précaution que je regrette pas
aujourd'hui vous savez pour combien vous
en avez pour quand même temps vous en
avez en tout cas le médecin vous à vous
a pronostiqué de maladie je pense que à
terme on va rentrer à la maison qui on
continuera notre isolement la maison
encore en observation à l'hôpital
vous savez pourquoi la haute savoie fait
partie des départements qui sont les
plus touchés aujourd'hui le cas 0
travail en lombardie et il y avait été
la semaine avant le 15 février puis la
semaine d'après et nous sommes jumelés
avec une une commune d'un côté de
conegliano donc une horde venise les
hennuyères ils ont déjà beaucoup de cas
paix dans toute la région
merci beaucoup françois davier une toute
dernière question il ya une question qui
se pose là depuis ces dernières heures
c'est sur la tenue des élections
municipales
est ce que pour vous ça vous paraît
réaliste d'avoir le scrutin dans une
quinzaine de jours maintenant surtout
paraître compliqué parce que tout le
monde est confiné au départ jusqu'au 14
puis maintenant avec les nouvelles
directives jusqu'à nouvel ordre
je vois pas alors que tout le personnel
de la mairie
c'est bloqué jusqu'au 14 comment on peut
organiser le 15 c'est vrai que c'est une
vraie question monsieur le préfet je
pense nous apportera la réponse dans les
jours qui suivent savez vous merci
beaucoup d'avoir été en direct avec nous
et puis bon rétablissement
où vous vous trouvez et puis vous nous
tenez au courant quand vous sortez de
l'hôpital et on sera avec vous en direct
sur sur figaro live merci beaucoup
françois davier donc je rappelle que
vous êtes maire de balme de sillingy en
haute savoie où il ya un certain nombre
de cas qui ont été détectés dont ce le
sien celui de françois xavier qui est
actuellement à l'hôpital